any tips for finding a mentor MH yeah
yeah don't ask for one yeah I sometimes
do get emails being like will you be my
mentor like random people like I'm
pretty sure it's not how it works yeah
don't don't ask one and first of all I
think you need to work out what it is
you want to learn so um I might say one
of the things that I want to learn about
is uh commercial skills or investing
actually that's one of the things that I
want to learn about I think amazing if
our um my business were thinking about
creating an investment fund so that
other people who are doing stuff in the
career space can we can help them to
grow we you know more than us just
operating the space and we want to
create an ecosystem of of squiggly
career support so um but I've not done
that before I don't know how to do it so
for me um who's done what I would like
to do a good Mentor would be somebody
who's maybe built some kind of
investment fund and they've got some
experience of doing that from scratch
and all everything that goes with it so
now I know what I want to learn I can
think about who I might think about who
do I know in my network that's got the
knowledge that I need and maybe maybe I
don't know anybody um so I could go to
somebody else that's in my network and
say do you know anyone who like we don't
always know everyone we might need to
know so it's fine to ask someone but you
can be very specific I'm not saying can
you introduce me to Ally I'm saying one
of the things that I'd really like to
learn is about investment funds do you
know anyone who and so it's it's it's
about the what before we get to the
person because otherwise I think people
just ask senior people to be the mentors
because it looks impressive and we've
got to be specific to be genuine and
then when we're making that request for
that person's time I think the way that
we are articulate that request is really
important so this is where we get to the
kind of the why I'm coming to you so
let's say you have got investment
experience that I would benefit from I
might say one of the things that I'm
really focused on is amazing ISS growth
and impact and one of the ways that I
think we can do that is by investing in
other people's businesses I know that
that is something that you have done
before and I think you've got a lot of
knowledge that I can learn from would
you be prepared to spend half an hour
with me just sharing the insights that
you got so that I can use that to inform
the the things that I'm planning to do
and like hell yeah of course if i' just
gone to you and said will you be my
mentor like that's like a recurring
commitment on my time I don't have time
like come on like who are you you know
that kind of thing who are you how much
time do you think I actually have like
like there's no it's too hard we don't
want to make it hard for people to help
us where people helping people I want to
make it as easy as possible for you to
help me now you and I might have that
meeting and that might be all I need
like you might just be like here's five
things that I think you should look at
see you later and and you still help me
right it's still been useful or you and
I might have that meeting and there
might have been some kind of connection
you're like oh I think fine what you're
doing is really interesting I'd actually
quite like to see how it goes and how it
grows and I'm like and you know loads
more than I've got out of you in 30
minutes and because we've got that sense
of connection that conversation is
likely to continue now this is really
really important for the Mente the
mentee needs to follow up if if the
mentee wants that conversation to
continue so if I'm like I really want to
see you again because there's a lot more
that I could learn from you it's really
important that after that meeting not
same day like give it a few days
actually do something with what that
person has shared follow up with the
mentor so go back to the mentor say
thank you so much for your time as a
result of this conversation these are
the things that I've already done um I
really appreciate it and I would love to
continue the conversation if you're up
for another meeting in the future and
because the mentor gets two boosts in
their brain the first boost is when they
helped like when you me help you're like
made me feel good help is high people
are helping people second boost is when
you know the impact of your efforts so
when I play it back to you you're like
oh that was a good use of my time she's
done something with what I gave her and
therefore you're much more likely to
give it again so I think if we can
approach mentoring a bit like that it's
I think it's better for both parties
yeah and the word Mentor is like never
even used yeah yeah just I just help and
knowledge and like that's more yeah I
think people under underappreciate
because I I feel like a limiting belief
a lot of people have is oh why would the
why would this person this important
person want to talk to me about the
thing I I don't realize it like if you
approach it in the right way it's just
it's just nice to everyone loves sharing
what they've learned and someone to be
interested in that and for that person
especially to then take action on
applying the thing you're like oh sick
yeah and you might even become friends
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye-bye